really brilliant to have you here my
name is Lisa Schultz I'm from the
Stockholm resilience center and I will
moderate this dialogue on water and
climate change and I'm very honored to
have with me three fantastic panelists
please come on stage and welcome Julian
Doubt's well glaciologists Steven Chu
Nobel laureate and you are upstream
environmental scientist please have a
seat and now we will move from the fresh
water into this vast topic of climate
change that you all the three all three
of you are heavily engaged in this field
but I would like you to first paint that
picture of how water and climate change
actually are connected maybe I can begin
with you Steven well it's actually where
do you be where do I begin with that
it's connected in so many ways a warmer
climate means the glaciers melt glaciers
melting changes the lanta currents and
the South going card which means the
Antarctica will be melting faster and
faster run off because the grounding
liners versus parent warmer climate
means more evaporation but it's not
going to come as water for everyone
everywhere it's a rich get richer and
the poor get poorer so in wet places at
wet times there's more and dry places
dry times there's even predictions
they'll be less so these things get
exaggerated and we're expecting many
more downpours at the wrong times not
during growing seasons but in things
that actually dissipate the snowmelt so
it's everywhere do we see these
repercussions I could take on there I
mean I think it's important for us to
recognize that you know have a
hydrologist colleague who often reminds
me that if mitigation is about gases
adaptation is about water which is a way
to say that victim number one of climate
change is water it's are either too much
or too little at the wrong time and
that's exactly what what Steven is
pointing out here
but the second issue that I think is
important for for us as a water
community also to to embed in our
thinking is that water is the blood
stream of the biosphere and the
biosphere is the carbon sink on the
planet so if you don't have functioning
ecosystems which fundamentally can only
exist if the hydrological cycle operates
and the whole photosynthesis and you
know the capturing of carbon and the
release of carbon without that we don't
have neither vegetation nor animals nor
microbes nor carbon in the soils we have
600 gigatonnes of carbon in the 50
centimeter top layer of soils moon in
Swedish now how do you get that well you
get it only if you have water because
it's only through the water cycle and
the photosynthesis interacting that you
can build up that organic carbon in the
soil so of course water is the
fundamental prerequisite for having a
stable resilient Earth system of engines
in all of this well when I started doing
polar research almost 40 years ago the
polar regions were really regarded as
being interesting but a little quirky
why was why were the polar regions
really of relevance interesting and they
people said well why on this chap got a
beard he can't have gone to the polar
regions but today there's a very strong
recognition that the polar regions are
major drivers of the global ocean
circulation through the formation or
lack of formation of sea ice in the
world which is warming the generation of
dense bottom water and the way that that
feeds into currents that drive the North
Atlantic circulation for example and in
the same way for glaciers and ice sheets
the Antarctic Ice Sheet the Greenland
ice sheet and the large ice masses on
the mountain areas of the world are
almost all with the exception of the
East Antarctic Ice Sheet melting rather
rapidly and that of course is one of the
two major decadal level controls on
global sea level change I mean I think
it's good to remind us that when we are
in deep Ice Age which we were like
20,000 years back we have 100 meters
lower sea level on planet Earth
so I mean Greenland and Antarctica holds
over hundred meters of sea level
potential just just in the ice I mean
these are big big dynamics and also to
remember that in a world one degree
warmer than today on average the sea
level was six to nine meters higher than
it is today as a matter of history
record not not climate models 69 meters
while 10 meters 10 percent of the
population of the earth lives within 10
meters of sea level and so the UN goal
is to stay to 6 to 9 meters and we were
just chatting about this walking in here
Steve and I that you know it's really
important to remember that 1 degree
Celsius is several me to sea level rise
2 degree cells is the last time we were
there 130,000 years back we know was
more than eight meters ceiling rise
again based on observations not models
and of course that won't happen
overnight
it will happen over perhaps two three
four centuries but is that a long time
we asked ourselves because after all we
depend on for example religious beliefs
and scriptures that were more than 2,000
years old so the question is what moral
responsibility do we have for a livable
planet not over the next 50 years but
even over the next 300 years yes and
when do we press the on button where we
irreversibly commit the Arctic and
Greenland and the Antarctic ax to
melting that might be very soon even
though the eight meters may play out
over pairs that the economy for example
is completely unable to capture through
discount rates one of the nobel prices
that were or prices in the in the memory
of nobel that was awarded this year to
an economist who has been able to bring
in the climate into economic models in a
way which is a big big breakthrough for
economy but comes to a different answer
about what is a reasonable warming
any any comments on that well let me
begin with that i and so building our
houses actually come along it was a
person you're speaking about it has come
a long way but still there's a little
bit of a difference because but
fundamentally you have to it's a
cost-benefit analysis and in that
cost-benefit analysis
there's something called a discount rate
if you take a dollar today and spend it
on something or you spend it a hundred
years from today it would be your the
dollar would grow and your economy would
be stronger and you would have more to
spend and so the issue is what discount
rates should you choose traditional
discount rates 30 20 30 40 year business
cycle times to actually discount
virtually everything to zero in 30 or 40
years there is no experience that goes
beyond one century and so this is the
fundamental problem that if you're
baking in something and some glacier
experts think that already the
commitment of the runoff of glaciers
because the grounding line friction that
blows beneath the sea level has been
eroded back so these glaciers are
running off now some of them at a
kilometer per year is it's already
committed even if you hold the
temperatures same they run run run off
it's like an avalanche I think what
we're saying is that the world doesn't
necessarily modify in this kind of way
it's a very threshold II world and a lot
of the environmental thresholds are
coming together and and the grounding
line of ice sheets is one very large
example of that the grounding line of
ice sheets is where they become
decoupled from the seafloor and the
problem is with Antarctica that the sea
floor actually becomes deeper as you go
towards the center of the continent and
that means that there are big buoyancy
problems and if you start off unpinning
the ice from a certain point it will go
back and back and back into deeper water
and this is a threshold vulnerability
but going back to the original question
there is no discount rate for a hundred
years from today it all discounts to
zero so if you care about what happens
to hundred years from there the
traditional economist will say no it's
whatever you spend today is value this a
hundred years from today and so this is
this is something new in society which
in simple words means that if you care
about the future these models don't work
another way it's a simple just just kind
of putting it to bits of intent to the
point but but that's that that aside
let me just also add them that like like
all of us I would say here we have great
respects to to the enormous
contributions that the Lord has has done
the number one then established
economist to integrate the climate and
macroeconomic analysis he was actually
ready in the seventies a person who
warned us that going beyond 2 degree
Celsius was dangerous he's a person
who's really taken this field very far
I'm today heading an institute that
builds very much on Bill Nordhaus
integrated assessment modeling work but
let me just show you one take that I
have on his science which i think is a
remind of the transformation we're
facing so in his latest runs of a dice
model he shows that the most
cost-effective temperature if you do
apply the kind of conventional
macroeconomic analysis on costs and
discount rate is three and a half degree
Celsius well if you add up all the
national determined contributions of all
the countries in the world from Paris it
leads to what three point five degrees
surprise surprise
can this be a coincidence could it be a
coincidence that when countries put
their businesses usual pathway it takes
us to three point five and we'll bill
Nordhaus applies that businesses usual
mechanics it leads to three point five I
think this is a proof that the economy
doesn't work so I think he's putting a
lot of evidence that we need to shift
gear into a new tech new way of thinking
and one of the thinking's is that you
need a price on carbon which bill
Nordhausen says himself says is needed I
think it's also a proof of the
limitations of our macroeconomic
analysis and I would say it goes really
back to Sweden here because it means
that what we call a Swedish some mistake
enormous consequence analyse is it has
great limitations has great limitations
although I don't think the bill nor
house actually thinks what he was doing
he thinks this is the best lowest cost
solution from what I read I'm taking a
very positive notion of tipping points
and thresholds because that's also I
think something that's hard to put into
these models and that's one of the
reasons why it looks as if a point
finding case would be reasonable warming
because then you're not really bringing
in the tipping points of Antarctica the
tipping point of coral
reefs and other tipping points in the
earth system that you have been able to
point out but if you look at his book
there is an asterisk in his book that
says I am NOT putting in any kipping
points if there are tipping points all
bets are off but so if these asterixis
need to be watched very carefully the
devil is in the detail as we say and the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change report has exactly the same
asterisk to do with its prediction for
the last prediction the new one is
coming out shortly its last prediction
of global sea-level which was actually
between point to only point two we don't
think point two is anywhere near what
will happen is gonna be far more than
that point two and point eight of a
meter by 2100 now why is that the
Asterix says but actually we don't we
are not counting anything to do with
possible thresholds that I just
described to do with grounding line
retreat because we can model them at the
moment so poorly so this is the sort of
challenge that even within the Glacia
logical community we have is to model
those kind of thresholds where there is
I swear there is ocean and where various
atmosphere all involved we are finding
it very very difficult to do that a lot
of what we need to know is hidden
beneath two or three kilometers of ice
it's very difficult to see what's going
on what's going on of that interface so
we can't even do that yet so putting all
these things together an economic model
seems to me to be very difficult and
this is ignoring the tipping point of
the methane in in the frozen tundra
which is which is is a very serious one
and so and then you say well we're gonna
ignore it even though we think if you
wild guess at three and a half degrees
you know reasonably probable that some
methane comes out lots of methane comes
out the danger of that is once the
methane starts to come out further warms
actually no matter what humans do after
that the greenhouse gas emissions from
just the methane will take you the rest
of the way to the usual state of the
planet which was you know five and 10 20
degrees warmer this is the history of
our planet so given this you studies
study these systems every day and you
see these different tipping points
coming how worried are you about the
future
I'm scared to death scared to death yeah
yeah I'm pretty worried if you if you
look at the changes that have gone on
just in the last 10 or 15 years in in
Arctic sea ice it's a complete
revolution in the nature of the Arctic
and how we can access it and so on it's
a huge change of course the Arctic is or
is almost an arguably the most sensitive
part of the global climate system but
that is very scary I think and you want
are you worried well if Steven is dead
scared that I'm dead scared as well
yeah well I'm alive it's here but I'd
like to kind of qualify my statement
slightly which is that if I'm not I'm
not dead scared purely on natural
science I would say that the natural
science today shows that despite all the
all the stress that we have posed on the
earth system and then all the
unsustainable hockey-stick patterns we
have seen over the last 50 years not
only on climate but also on the
biosphere we still live on on a
reasonably resilient planet
it still has dominant dominated by
negative feedbacks the oceans still take
up heat we have still carbon
sequestration occurring we don't have
the massive release of methane we have
ice melt but it hasn't collapsed to a
point where we can say yet cooling so
you could argue that natural
scientifically the window is still but
barely but still open to be able to fear
below two degrees Celsius and stay
within a manageable integrational state
the nervousness arises when you look at
the inertia of our inability to act and
I think that when you put that together
I think that's where what makes I think
I get very nervous when we see what's
happening in a world today where we have
two years to bend the global carbon
emissions and we need to cut the
missions by half over the next 12 years
we know we can't do it we know we must
do it but will we do it and I think that
is where the real nervousness arises
that is not pure natural science I air
in a way I agree a little bit of more
optimism the technology is advancing
very very rapidly and so there are good
things on
the more appreciation of how this
connected system can be made to have
better solutions and much better
technical solutions but the window is
closing to get to the not the one point
five degree but the two degree goal
virtually every scenario there says that
by 2080 roughly the entire greenhouse
gas emissions carbon emissions of the
world including agriculture including
process heat including transportation as
well as electricity generation
everything has to go negative for the
entire world so that's the challenge it
has to be negative meaning we can't not
only stop producing carbon dioxide and
all the other greenhouse gases we
actually have to be sucking it from the
atmosphere in order to get two degrees
and I think from that big realization I
mean you've all all three of you have
our scientists who have also moved more
into having an impact on society and
even you even were in government under
Obama and and so in this work that you
are all are doing what gives you hope
and where this inspiring action being
taken on this challenges for Humanity on
water in climate
well you know I mean I learned this from
my PhD thesis advisor it's not too late
until you're dead but he was very wise
man but I would also say if you give up
hope even if you're and this is hope for
fifty and a hundred and 150 years from
today then you are actually advocating
some real deep oral responsibility for
this because I will I won't be around
where most of this stuff hits the fan
but that's a physics colloquial
expression but but seriously the you
know we are not going to be leaving our
children grandchildren better
world and this is very serious and so
that's why we have to work very hard so
we can get there and as you say to bend
the curve and we need to start bending
in a couple of decades do you see any
exciting opportunities opening or
inspiring action being taken oh
definitely I think we're living in a
it's a very important tipping point we
are in right now that the world is will
we be tipping back to our status quo
will be decisively tipped towards a
transformation where we will bend the
curve which was on its way to be bent by
the way 2014 to 2016 I think we are in a
place now where businesses are stepping
up in a very significant way at scale as
I shared during my talk it is even
surprising to me that we have only over
50 countries in the world that has a
doctor a price on carbon but behind
there behind that there over 700
companies multinational international
companies that have adopted a shadow
price on carbon so I think there is a
you know a sense of inevitability of a
transition towards a decarbonized future
it's just the question will we do it
fast enough and I think that is quite
promising I think that when Volkswagen
just last week announced publicly that
it sees an end date on the combustion
engine saying that will sell no more
combustion engine cars from 2040 a bit
late ish but but it's a it's significant
it's of course a reaction on a deep
crisis but it tells you that we have
really reached the beginning of the end
of the fossil fuel era and what we know
which is Stevens point which is so
important is that we're coming to this
beginning of the end not based on an
environmental problem but based on an
innovation pathway which means that we
see more and more evidence that this can
actually be a self propelling exercise
just like the Moore's law basically
because we can make money along the way
and we can have better outcomes for
society so I think there's a there is
hope in that sense the question is just
will we be able to scale and I think
education is just such an important
thing and might my observation having
taught students for for 40 odd years is
that the students who are coming through
today are very much more aware than
previous generations of the problems
that there are and actually are
demonstrating a very strong willingness
to address those problems and I think
younger people are in a way our hope in
part because they carry the message yeah
I think today we see really kids
stepping up there and and demanding a
future basically from the from from us I
I wanted to give the opportunity to also
to the audience who have come all the
way here to listen to us to ask
questions to this panel so if you want
to ask the question raise your hand and
there will be a mic coming here we have
one and it's important that you wait for
the mic so that our viewer viewers can
hear what you're saying are you
personally doing something against like
climate change so are you climate
compensating your flights or are you
eating vegetarian what are you doing as
a person well I think I fly all around
the world talking about climate change
at the irony ad Sonic's cape but I I
Drive 1200 miles a year I ride my
bicycle twice as many miles as I Drive a
car I actually we're on the bottom rung
of the lick name my wife and I in terms
of electricity use in California and so
there and we're eating less and less
meat for sure it's difficult to get to
the polar regions without using ships
and aircraft I'm afraid and I suppose
and I suppose you know the reason we do
it is because we think it's important
enough to try and understand change and
indeed importantly the rates of change
that are going on in those places that
we think that that matters enough that I
suppose we make that sacrifice of of
getting there in the ships and their
cross because that there really is no
other way to do it I mean that that's a
very good question and
myself and my family will also do as
much as we can but recognizing that it's
very challenging we try to operate as
much as we can along a carbon law to try
and cut our emissions by half and that
is proven in the beginning to be quite
easy actually - we have not two cars
only one cars a biogas car very small
car I go cycling on and everything I use
only public transport no other means of
transport you know pulling down very
significantly not only on meat actually
but not throwing food whatsoever trying
to you know go on vacation in Sweden
instead of going elsewhere using train
as much as possible but still
recognizing that yeah my teenager just
said hello from Verbier where he is
right now as a ski teacher and you know
that was through aircraft so it is a
struggle all the way but I think we can
do a lot but I always try to answer that
questions by saying that the number one
task for us is not to get depressed and
saying that we should load all the
responsibility all on your shoulders on
my shoulders this is a societal
transformation and we need to also talk
about this share the knowledge have our
ears on the ground on the science and
quite frankly make our voices heard as
much as possible so that democratic
processes can can can really move on the
societal suit because easier for us to
live in a decarbonized modern world so
it's good it goes both ways and it's
really also about expanding your
identity from being a consumer to being
a citizen I think and and an activist
and there are so many ways that you can
influence this transformation beyond
your lifestyle choices although they are
of course very important and you can
make a big impact through your lifestyle
choices you can make an even bigger
impact through your conversations where
you work and what you decide to put your
energy on and and and how you vote and
and things like that so but thanks for a
great question we can have one more
question there was one over there that I
saw first if you can get to the
gentleman I think keep your keep your
hand raised yes you so that the mic can
find
[Music]
that's corporation no one is grabbing
the mic into the turn okay thank you
thank you how important is population
control in reaching the carbon targets
that we're seeking population control
how important is that maybe for water
and climate
well it's essential we're seven 1/2
going to nine ish nine and a half
mid-century the good news is as people
grow wealthier they have fewer kids and
so actually if you accelerate wealth
creation in developing countries you can
actually you have to bend that curve and
you have to bend it and then the
economists have to think of economic
models which is not dependent on
business growth because their whole
model is is you just consume more you
make more you do some more stuff and
this is not a sustainable model clearly
but yet there's no economists willing to
say no no no we've got to get it so that
you can actually have a higher standard
of living with a shrinking population so
but it's very real with more education
especially with women you have smaller
families and and and and then then
everybody says no but you need at least
two kids no it's it's okay to go back to
five million billion or eight billion
you know I agree with Stephen but I also
agree with with a great hero late
colleague Hans Rosling who who reminds
us every time that we have bent down the
transition curve with regard to
demographics already so even though
population continues growing we have
actually started the decline in
fertility per per adult woman in the
world however over the next thirty years
is very difficult to bend to change the
pattern because these are very slow
variables and we know that it's over the
next 10 20 years that will determine
whether or not we will be decisively
moving too
decarbonized future so I think we have
to remind ourselves all the time that we
in the rich world are omitting you know
roughly five tonnes per capita per year
on domestic emissions but roughly ten
per capita if we include consumption and
that is ten times more than the African
average so of course it's it's it's has
to be recognized all the time that the
rich per capita emissions are those that
need to coat how fast list even though
population is really important and in
the media it's very difficult to change
the curve but of course we have to do
everything we can to avoid that Africa
becomes what can it be three four
billion people almost instead of you
know it's projections I mean the low
high projections are just the difference
between manageable and and unmanageable
but it is distressing that the developed
countries are now encouraging their
quote native populations to have higher
fertility and and this this is this so
they I go back to no we need a different
model than their that's important thank
you i we have a few minutes left and i
would like to just speak a bit about the
role of of science because i think
you've all stepped out a bit of the of
the conventional way of doing science in
your endeavor and I think sparked by
your realization of how severe this
issues are that you're scared to death
and that leaves you I think to to do
science a bit differently maybe than you
did then then is normally done so can
you speak a bit about that the future
role of science in contributing to
addressing these challenges
I mean concerning the polar regions I'm
still very much practicing scientist and
what I shall be doing next is going out
on an icebreaker to Antarctica in about
three weeks time to study exactly one of
the problems and the Steven mentioned
first and I mentioned too
that is to say how stable are these
floating ice shelves which are
buttressing much of the ice on the
interior of Antarctica and are one of
the most major unknowns but one of the
most important potential
practice concerning sea-level rise both
its absolute magnitude and its rate of
rise over the next 50 to 200 years so we
shall be using autonomous underwater
vehicles to look into probably the least
known places on planet planet earth the
immense cavitus beneath hundreds of
metres of ice at the periphery of
Antarctica to try and work out various
parameters such as roughness and
turbulence to input to the numerical
models which will help us to understand
better how stable these features are on
timescales of decades so that if you
like is practicing signs and it feeds
into the points that you two are making
I think but it's a small part of your
whole and it's really about closing
those knowledge gaps that we still have
about how the planet operates on how
these glaciers actually work and I think
there are certain things that are
particularly important that we don't
know about at the moment and that
buttressing effect and the stability
that the resilience of ice shows is is
one of the critical parameters because
it fundamentally affects whether we're
talking about less than a meter or meter
of sea level rise and maybe two or
two-and-a-half on the timescale of a
couple hundred years so this is this is
serious stuff it's a particular kind of
science but it does matter yes and I
would add that I also do most of lion's
share of my time it's actually doing
what you would call traditional science
but it's it's gone and tell the things
because of the energy climate issues I
Do's I'm trying to make better batteries
we would like to make a battery that has
four times higher energy density but
four times faster charging so that you
get a 150 mile range out of total 300
miles in five minutes six minutes when
you get that the game is over personal
vehicles go to electrification which
gets much cleaner and electrochemistry I
also do biology research and biomedical
research and they're only in my spare
time do I actually worry about water and
climate and things like that but you
know so it's like the first 70 hours
goes to science by the next 30
I can lavish on other things and my goal
about keeping a carbon footprint is as
my wife knows I don't take vacations
[Laughter]
research focus a bit put our energy
matter right especially if you can get
the newer people that their ingenuity
and and things will give us even better
choices that will accelerate what we
need where we need to go next
I almost forgot my line here because I
thought that taking no vacations I might
consider what about no eating no
seriously actually a starvation diet no
jokes aside I mean one fundamental
research tasks at the Potsdam Institute
with very close collaboration which talk
of resilience enter is is of course to
dig even deeper into understanding earth
resilience and and what at what
temperature rise are we really at risk
of passing thresholds that irreversibly
would change the feedback dynamics and
cross tipping points I mean that's I
think a very important task for the
interdisciplinary Earth System science
but equally important is the big quest
of answering the following question what
are the social tipping points that can
unleash large-scale disruptive changes
in a desirable direction what lessons
can we learn from history and what can
we do in the future to really ramp up
disruptive change in in in the digital
world we live in so that's a second
strand of research and then finally
where I think we connect very closely as
you know Big Data machine learning and
artificial intelligence is entering the
stage of Earth System research and
global sustainability you know
fast pace and soon will have the ability
you know to use supercomputers to really
understand the dynamics of both the
Arctic and Antarctica with human
behaviors across scale that we've never
dreamed of in the past so we're putting
quite a big investment actually right
now and in artificial intelligence for
Earth System research which is one of
these frontier areas where we quite
frankly don't know where we're heading
but it will be very distinct - you know
if any one of you were interested in
that let's follow up on this so I would
say that that to be scared to death I
think is sound very excited also and I
do think that the times has that that
feature but it is very interesting
interesting times and it is about really
understanding our future and I would
like to end just with the coating agree
a tattoo in the body this 15 year old
who is now really an activist who's
making politicians across the globe
listen to kids and she says that hope is
important but hope really comes from
action actually it's more important more
more important because from action comes
hope and I think that's that's a good
ending of this panel thank you so much
for your time thank you
[Applause]